[Musique]
eric zemmour est une baudruche qui va se
dégonfler je ne sais pas mais enfin pour
l'instant il n'est pas candidat déclaré
il envoi desdits sollicite des
formulaires de parrainages auprès des
maires alors que le maire raccompagne
des mariés à la sortie de l'hôtel de
ville celui ci se fait en farine et par
des membres de la ligue de défense noire
africaine plus tard plusieurs dizaines
d'individus rentrer à l'intérieur de la
mairie une élus tentent de s'opposer à
leur venue la force de diaboliser les
uns ou les autres on leur donne une
importance qu'ils ne méritent pas les
ablettes martichoux c'est exactement ce
que je crois diaboliser quelqu'un lui
donne une importance qu'il n'a pas en
accord je trouve trop d'importance eric
zemmour il faut combattre ses idées
c'est tout tout est parti d'une bagarre
entre enfants d'une dizaine d'années une
semaine plus tôt les parents s'interpose
mais le ton monte et les coups pleuvent
entre les deux pères l'un d'origine
kurde et l'autre de nationalité
sénégalaise s'en suit un rassemblement
procure de non autorisées dans lequel
des insultes et des propos racistes sont
tenus j'ai été très fier quand manuel
valls était premier ministre et anne
hidalgo maire de paris il n'y a pas
d'autres pays au monde qui pouvait avoir
comme chef de l'exécutif et comme maire
de la principale ville deux immigrés
devenus français et qui étaient vraiment
l'exemple absolu d'assimilation fait un
pied de nez dont monsieur zemmour
devrait s'inspirer c'est une candidature
qui se résume à des bons sentiments des
lieux comment tout ça pour faire oublier
sa gestion catastrophique de paris vous
le savez tous vous êtes mère de famille
qui est devenu paris sous la mandature
d'anne hidalgo j'ai été un peu déçu hier
à cause de l'estiment que j'ai pour elle
par la premières bêtises qu'elle a dites
c'est à dire le doublement des salaires
des fonctionnaires et joseph peyré ans
même qu'elle nous en sortir a pas
beaucoup comme ça elle va venir vous
mordre les mollets là dans le socle
lectorat madame hidalgo c'est possible
mais il ya moins d'un missile qu'elle le
croit pas parmi les gens qui votent pour
moi donc il faut pas prendre les gens
pour des imbéciles vouloir proposer un
truc dont ils savent eux-mêmes que ça
tient pas debout la f10 est dit ça pour
ma patte et puis demain
examen on ne sera plus avec nous à
partir de ce soir je viens de raccrocher
avec lui et vous transmet ses
salutations vous remercie de l'avoir
encouragé pendant deux ans il se dit
député dépité pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22
je soutiendrai le président de la
république je pense j'espère qu'il sera
candidat pense que c'était inévitable je
pense que le csa l'a fait exprès l'a
fait volontairement et c'est pas une
surprise je connais parfaitement edouard
philippe depuis des années je me doutais
bien qu'il soutiendrait une aile macron
c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour nous
tous un débat avec philippe martinez à
la fête de l'humanité c'est quand même
pas évident pour gouvernement bah non
c'est sûr je m'attends pas à être
acclamé si c'est la question est
effectivement ça n'a pas été simple
qu'est ce que vous allez faire là dedans
c'est pas bon déjeuner si je ne suis pas
encore là mais
c'est pas gd je réfléchis voudrait ça
changeait parlement depuis samedi
dimanche et à la violence des coups ça
peut vous faire réfléchir alors là je
vais vous dire la violence des coups ça
plutôt me donne envie de me battre
encore plus
[Musique]
son rêve de jeunesse se réalise en ce
moment même à paris empaqueter l'arc de
triomphe avec plusieurs centaines de
mètres carrés de tissus argent bleuté
maintenu par des cordages rouge j'ai
vraiment beaucoup de vague à l'âme au ce
matin je me réveille en me disant voilà
c'est fini deux ans d'une aventure
extraordinaire
j'ai découvert des gens
merveilleux christine marc meneau
dimitri bonne nouvelle on vient de
retrouver le tout le papier toilette qui
était en rupture de stock les magasins
pour le premier confinement vous savez
on dit toujours que
la plus d'amis après l'adolescence et en
fait j'ai découvert que c'est faux
[Musique]
tisha